[Music]
Welcome everybody. Thanks for showing up
bright and early this morning. We're
going to make your life easier for Rag.
So just hang in there. If you want to
get started, we have the link right
there, contextual.ai25.
That's going to get you a notebook. It's
going to get you the getting started
link which will get you an API key that
you'll be able to use for the notebook.
So feel free to jump ahead and start on
those pieces like that. All right. So
let me first introduce the team that's
here. So I'm Rajie Sha. I'm the chief
evangelist of contextual AI. So I do a
lot of these talks, workshops. I
endlessly talk about AI which I'm kind
of in this position. For background,
I've been in the AI space for a while.
Before this, I was over at Hugging Face
for a number of years as well. So,
besides me talking, we also have Nina.
You want to introduce yourself? Hi, I'm
Nina. I'll be presenting along with Raj.
This is my fourth week at Contextual.
So, very exciting for me. Uh, thank you
all for joining us this morning. I've
been working in NLP and language
modeling for the past seven or eight
years. um really since uh BERT was
considered a large language model and uh
I'm excited to show you how you can uh
simplify your rack pipeline with
contextual today. Thanks. And besides
Nina, we also have two other members of
our team that are in the back that if
you raise your hand and have questions,
they will come to you. So one of them is
Matthew who's a platform engineer. So if
you have questions about how we scale
up, what's what are the things going on
in the back end, he's the person for
you. We also have John on our team who's
one of the solution architects. So if
you're like, "Hey, how would I integrate
this into my environment?" He's the guy
who's going to be able to handle that as
well. So let's kick this off. What I
want to do is for you to all get one of
the big pieces out of this is we can
treat Rag like a managed service. We
don't go out anymore and train our own
language large language models. If we're
working with embeddings, we don't build
our own vector databases. Same thing
with Rag. We can treat Rag just like any
other managed service.
And so what we're going to do today is
I'm going to do this quick introduction
here, but then we're going to get you
started right away with building this
rag agent with ingesting some files and
Nina and I will go back and forth where
I'll go and give you a bit more of an
overview of contextual. You'll build an
agent, run a number of queries against
it, get a feel for it, and then I'll do
a deep dive on some of the advanced
settings that developers like around
extraction, reranking, retrieval like
that. Then we'll end with a little bit
on evaluation as well as how you can use
um MCP for example and connect your rag
agent to cloud desktop as well.
Now, to start with, we all know the
value of AI, right? We're all here
because of the importance of AI. But for
many of you also know the struggles of
AI. How it's easy to build that demo
with 10 documents when you're doing rag.
But when you go to scale that out, all
of a sudden it's hard to extract across
thousands of documents of diversity,
right? Your accuracy isn't there. Your
users are complaining that they aren't
happy with it because they don't know
how to query properly.
Now what we at we at contextual have
focused on this. So our founders here
Dao and Aman come from working on rag
for a long time. Dao was an author was
leading the team on the initial rag
paper. Aman was with him at meta. I knew
both of them from my time at hugging
face where I was helping people do rag
years ago on question answer systems and
I would be able to pull their
researchers in to help work with
customers as I was cobbling together
kind of open- source components to build
these pipelines. Well, they saw the need
in that. They want to change how the
world works and so contextual has come
around for focusing on enterprise and we
still have this dedication to AI
research and you'll see that as we go
through our product as well.
Now for again just the basics just in
case there's somebody in here not
familiar with it right when we're
talking about rag retrieval augmented
generation the value here is when you
have lots of that unstructured
enterprise data we want to be able to
understand it so rag allows us to take
that information
a simplifi a very simple rag pipeline
uses a vector database to keep all of
that use cosine similarity to find
similar pieces, pass it to an LLM.
That's the simplest. We're going to get
much more complicated today like that.
And what I want to do is show off our
platform to you. The platform is built
for a couple of different levels. So,
one is there's a no code. So, if you're
a business user, you just have a bunch
of docs. You want to be able to ask
questions to them. We've made it very
simple with opinionated defaults on
that. Now, if you're a developer on the
other hand, you know what you want in
your rag pipeline. You're spending time
evaluating it. You're spending time
tweaking it. Well, we've built a
platform where you can then orchestrate
and change how do I want to do quering?
How do I want to do generation along the
ways? And finally, some of you might
already have rag, you might already have
rag pipelines in production where
there's just a one component that isn't
working that well. Maybe your extraction
isn't working that well or you want a
better ranker. Well, we've made our
system modular. So if you just want to
use one piece of it, you can.
And all we focus on is Rag. Other
companies focus on other pieces. We just
think about building rag. And again, the
reason we're here is as you go and try
to do this in production, you'll see
like once you get to lots of documents,
it gets messy. All of a sudden, then
you're orchestrating a big environment
full of lots of different models. Now I
need a BM25, I need a reranker. putting
all that stuff together ends up sucking
up your time. It's fun to do the first
time, but after that it ends up sucking
up your time, ends up with slow kind of
costly um rag pieces. So, that's enough
to get started. I'm going to turn it
over to Nina who's going to get you
started on building that first agent.
All right, we're on the clock. 15
minutes to get our agent up and running.
Um, just kidding. We'll take a little
longer than that to explain everything.
But how you can get started is um you
can find the notebook and the getting
started page at contextual.ai25.
And then the guey for contextual is at
app.contextual.ai.
That's what that getting started button
will point you to. And so we're going to
start by loading a few documents. Um,
we're going to load some financial
statements from Nvidia and some fun
speurious correlations to see how our
rag system treats data that's not uh
fitting with conventional wisdom. And
then we'll try out a few queries uh in
including quantitative reasoning over
tables and some data interpretation. And
so I'm gonna have uh these two screens
here side by side. The notebook on the
left and the platform on the right. So
you can get started by signing up in the
platform if you haven't already. That's
at app.contextual.ai.
That's where you're going to get your
API key. So everyone take maybe a minute
or so. You'll need to log into that and
uh you'll need to set up your workspace.
I already have my workspace set up and
I'm actually using uh my rec uh not my
work account just so that you'll see
exactly um what a general access user
would see on their screen on my screen.
And just a tip for setting up those
workspace names, it's going to have to
be a unique name. So you can't call it
AIE-demo.
I just throw my name into the names just
to make it a little bit more unique. So,
um, so everyone just, uh, take a minute
to do that. And, uh, to help you get a
sense of where folks are, just briefly
raise your hand and put it down once you
have your workspace set up and you see
this welcome screen.
Okay, folks are making fast progress.
Um,
yes, Matthew.
Yeah,
thanks.
Um, so yeah, so we can start by in the
notebook doing our pip installs. Oh,
start by making a copy of the notebook.
So you can just do go to file, save a
copy and drive
and then that will create a copy for you
of the notebook so that you can save
whatever changes you're making to it if
you want to make any changes.
It is a bit slowly making a copy. Um,
but yeah, after the pip installs and the
imports to get your API key, you go into
your contextual app, click on API keys
here on the right,
save a copy of the notebook and then in
our contextual platform on the right,
you can go to API keys. Um, click on
create API key. So, Nenina,
Nina, key 2 is my name. And then we'll
copy that. And then we can go to our
notebook secrets on the left here, the
key there. And then add a new secret.
And then you'll just add contextual
API key. Yeah, it's refreshing. Um, but
if yours is working, then uh you can
I'll just do it in the notebook without
making a copy. Contextual
API key and then just paste the value
there and then you'll save that. Um,
and yeah, that's all that's the only API
key we need. For those of you that have
spun up rag on your own, it's often an
API scavenger hunt just to get started.
And this is literally the only API key
we're going to use for the whole rest of
the workshop. So we have just finished
the uh hardest part of setting this up.
So once we've saved those credentials,
then we're going to set up our client
here. So we're just going to uh run the
client in our notebook. So here I'm on
the left in the notebook and then we're
going to create our data store. So you
can change the name on this uh data
store name
variable. Um
and then it's going to see if there's an
existing data store or load that one.
Um and then after that, which seems to
still not be running.
Okay.
Yeah. After the pip installs and the
imports,
that data store is going to be where
you're going to be loading all of your
documents. And then we have
some code here in step two, uh, that
will download those files that I
mentioned earlier to your notebook. So
that's going to be a few quarterly
reports and
furious correlation reports. And so here
in step two, you'll see that it's
fetching the data and then uploading it
to the data store. And then you can go
to your app.contextual.ai.
And
uh this is the AIE demo data store that
I made just here. So if you click on
your documents, you'll see that they're
processing. And once they're done
processing, um, you can click on these
three dots. And then once the files are
loaded, you'll be able to inspect them
and see how those files have been parsed
and ingested. So I'll just take a quick
look at the run I did yesterday of all
these same exact files. Um,
and so if you click on inspect once your
files are loaded, for example, if you
have a table, you're going to see the
raw text and then also the rendered
preview. So you can see this table is uh
has both the structure and the contents
of the table in this image below. And
you're welcome to take a look at these.
Uh the numbers match very perfectly and
the structure. So that's kind of step
one of getting your rag system set up is
having really accurate parsing. And you
can look at some of the um image files.
We chose some spurious correlations
which are a fun way to test how much a
rag system will actually uh answer based
on your own documents rather than its
conventional wisdom. And so you can see
there also there will be raw text and uh
rendered previews um with like key data
points from figures and uh summaries of
the figures in addition to the text and
other information extracted. So while
your files are adjusting uh Raj will
come back and expand on the
uh on the platform. All
right, it seems to me I need to update
this slide with Wi-Fi issues as well.
But any of you who've built rag systems
before know that there's several
components of it, there's a lot of tasks
you have to do, right? You have to think
about building out an extraction
pipeline. Besides that, when you're
thinking about accuracy, how am I going
to chunk out? What am I going to do for
chunking? What am I going to do for
re-ranking? And then finally, you have
to think about scaling. There's a lot of
these issues that come up. And again,
it's interesting the first time you do
it, but maintaining this stuff after a
while gets tiresome. And that's where
contextual comes in where it's really an
end-to-end platform for managing rag.
And our platform runs in our SAS. It can
run in your VPC. We have a UI for those
business users, but we also have an API
rest API endpoints as well. And when the
within the platform, we manage all those
pieces for you. So you don't have to
worry about maintaining a vector store
for your embeddings. And the way it
works is you'll come with your
structured and unstructured data. We
bring that in. We have a document
understanding pipeline and that's the
extraction part that we're going to walk
through here where we need to cleanly be
able to pull all that information out of
your documents, your tables, your
images. Once we have that, we chunk that
up and then we go through the best
practices around retrieving. So we have
a mixture of retrievers, so BM25 as well
as an embedding model. We have a
state-of-the-art reranker that we've
trained ourselves that's in our pipeline
and then we pass it all to a grounded
language model. Now, we don't use a
model from OpenAI or Gemini. We trained
our own grounded language model because
for rag use cases, we want the model to
be grounded. We want it not to give its
own advice just because it can pass the
law exam or know everything about
medicine. We don't want it to use its
knowledge when it's answering questions.
we want it to instead stay grounded,
respect the context that we're giving
like that. And finally, there's lots of
different ways we can output this and
I'll show you this along the way as
well. Now, for each of these parts, we
have that academic pedigree as I
mentioned earlier. So, one thing we
always do is look at the academic
benchmarks. Nowadays, we have lots of
customer data set points that we use as
well. But whether we think about the
end-to-end accuracy of our platform or
the specific parts around document
understanding, retrieval, grounded
generation, each one of those we focused
on to make them state-of-the-art for
what they do like that. So once we've
done that, when you go to use them,
there's a lot of different uses that you
can have for this. I think often when we
think of initially of of rag, we think
about I'm going to build a question and
answer chatbot, right? Like I'm going to
ask a question, get back an answer.
Well, yes, that's one use of what you
can do with this. But we have customers
like Qualcomm who use contextual on
their website. So if you go live to
their website right now and you ask a
question there, it's powered by
contextual on the back end. And you can
see similarly the question the answers
right our feedback module sources are
all available there
besides that we have other customers for
example some folks in the finance
financial spectrum uh my audio
and they're thinking about automated
workflows how can I take all the
unstructured data I have structure it to
make it useful for folks well we have
APIs you can hook up those APIs be able
to run
against here.
Is it good?
Ah, okay. No worries. But we can take
all that unstructured use our rag agents
in in the context of something like a
spreadsheet or some other workflow to be
able to use that. Finally, we can
connect it with lots of other tools.
I'm going to put this in there even
though I know it's not going to work but
just for all of you we can show you and
I'm going to show you at the end here
today how you can for example integrate
the rag agents with something like
claude with MCP so that way you can take
advantage of the enterprise knowledge
that you have in there.
All right, so with that I'm going to
hand it back over to Nina and let's get
you started on your agents.
Looks like the Wi-Fi might be down
again.
Um
Um,
yeah, it looks like the speaker, Wi-Fi,
and my hotspot are not working. So,
we'll just continue with the notebook
and we'll talk through it and then uh I
guess is anyone else's Wi-Fi working?
Raise your hand if you have Wi-Fi.
Okay. Well, you guys can follow along.
You have the videos too, right? You have
the videos. I do have Oh. Oh, it's back
up. Okay, cool. Um, so yeah, where we
were in the notebook on the left here is
um hopefully all of your
uh data stores have loaded now. Um,
yes. So, assuming you had Wi-Fi to
upload them, uh, these are the ones I
just loaded in the workshop earlier. And
then in the notebook on the left, you
can see um that you can access these
files uh through the API just the same
as you can through the guey. And then
you can have the document metadata like
when it was created, the name, uh the
status of the ingestion. And now we're
going to create our agent. Uh so over
here we have our system prompt. Uh this
is kind of just our default system
prompt that the agents are loaded with.
And then you can run this next block of
code here on the left to set up your
agent. You can change the name if you'd
like. I called it demo- AIE. And then in
on the right in our guey, if you click
on agents, uh there it is. There's my
new agent right here that I just
created. And um and then you can put in
your question based on these documents.
So for example um one question that we
can ask is what was Nvidia's annual
revenue by fiscal year 2022 to 2025.
And so uh what you'll notice here is we
have our responses. What we provided was
quarterly data. So what the agent is
doing is adding that up and then listing
it here on the right and then noting
that this is based on quarterly data.
And then you'll see these little numbers
in a circle, the two and the one. So if
you click on the two here, you'll
actually see the
image that this data came from. Uh and
similarly, if you click on one, you'll
see the other image. So interestingly,
this came from two separate files that
were unrelated in any way. They actually
don't even have like a standard naming
convention for these. I pulled these
from the NVIDIA financial reports
website, and it knew to reference those
documents um to pull that information
across documents. And then you can do
the same exact thing that we just did
pro um in the guey programmatically. So
here in step four, we're running our
query uh and we're getting the exact
same response in the API. So this can
make it easier to integrate it into your
um into your application.
And so we can also here visualize which
files were used to reference in the API.
And so now we're printing uh the
documents here. The B 64 encoding is
getting returned with another API query.
Um so just because it's a more fun and
visual demo, uh we'll ask the next few
questions via the guey here. So uh
Nvidia used to be a gaming compute
company. So I'm going to ask the
chatbot, when did Nvidia's data center
revenue overtake gaming revenue? And so
um the crossover point was in Q1 fiscal
year 23
uh with data septer revenue at 3.7
million and gaming revenue at 3.6. And
then here I can click on the one here.
So that's Q1 fiscal year 23. And we can
look at our slide here and here it is.
That's actually like the exact crossover
point where uh data center revenue
overtook gaming revenue. Now, we're
going to look at the Spurious
correlation files uh that we've also
loaded. So, for those of you unfamiliar,
this is a website that uh basically data
crawls and finds correlations between
things that have no correlation. So,
we're searching for what's the
correlation between the distance uh
between Neptune and the sun and burglar
burglary rates in the US. That would be
some extreme astrology there if that
actually determined burglary rates. And
so what you'll find is that our rag
system that's really really focused on
avoiding hallucinations
um and really following the data that
you've loaded. It will give you that
correlation coefficient which is very
high but then it will also share that
context. Um so otherw elsewhere in the
document they talk about how they're
doing data dredging and um that this is
not really a valid statistical
correlation and so you can then also
reference where in that document these
claims were made both the statistical
correlation and the uh
and the the caveats which are not
loading I think from Wi-Fi issues but
you can test this out in your own
instance uh as well.
Um, we have another fun one that was uh
what's the correlation between global
revenue generated by Uni Lever Group and
Google searches for lost my wallet.
That's another spurious correlation that
we loaded and it will do the same thing.
It will give you the actual answer uh
and then note the caveats. And I'll note
that if you run these same queries in
chat GPT here on the right, if you just
ask the question without any files, not
doing rag, it will just start with
telling you there's no meaningful
correlation. We know that's true, but
think about if your own documents don't
follow conventional wisdom or have some
information that's not out there, it's
going to argue with the information in
your documents rather than presenting it
even though it may not be um may not
actually be true in this case. Uh, and
then if you do a document upload and use
the long context in chat GPT, you will
get that response of the actual
correlation, but then it will just say
it's a spurious correlation and it won't
really go into why. So, it's not really
going to um, you know, a simple system
like this is not really going to hue to
the facts that you've presented it with.
Um,
and
uh, for a fun question, we just searched
about uh, global revenue from Uni Lever
Group and Google searches for lost my
wallet. Does this imply that Uni Lover
Group's revenue is derived from lost
wallets? And it will answer no, that's
not true. Um, which we know. And then if
we ask another query that relates two
different documents that don't have any
information shared between them. Now
we're looking at the correlation between
the distance between Neptune and the sun
and global revenue generated by uni
level group. And it will not answer that
question. It will just say it does not
have that information. And so you know
these are all uh pretty straightforward
questions and answers but um you set up
with our default settings. But if you go
to your agent and you click on edit in
the admin panel, there's actually a lot
that you can change. If you know, for
example, that last question I asked, if
there was data that supported it and it
wasn't found or something, uh you can
check which data stores are linked. So
you can link multiple data stores. You
can adjust the system prompt and that is
uh also something you can do via API
that we'll go over briefly later.
There are some settings on query
understanding. So, we disabled
multi-turn in our setup just to have
everyone uh have the same consistent
responses as they're trying it to make
the workshop easier to follow. Um, you
can set up query expansion or
decomposition.
Uh you can set some retrieval settings,
settings for the reranker, settings for
the filter, including the prompt
generation settings, and you can even
set up a user experience where you have
suggested queries for the user. Um, and
so, uh, going back to our notebook here,
um, what we have next in the notebook is
going to be examples of code for some of
the components. So, these are the
individual components that make up the
full rag system. We won't run through
this in the workshop. I'm just going to
uh share what we have here before Raj
does a deeper dive into what these
components can do. So for each
component, we've shared a link to uh a
full a more complete notebook that lets
you use more features of that component.
We have our benchmarks uh that compare
it to other solutions. And then we have
a little bit of example code that will
run in the notebook um to try out these
components alone. And you don't need to
set up the it's the same API key that we
set up before. So everything will just
run. I will just say you want to uh let
your file process before you display it.
But in this example, uh, we're just
printing the first page of the attention
is all you need paper. We have our
reranker, which is the world's first
instruction following reranker, and
that's also a standalone subcomponent
that you can use independently of the
full platform. We have our generate
model that is uh, according to the
effect grounding benchmark, the most
grounded language model in the world.
That's available as a standalone
component. And here's some sample code
for that. And then uh after Raj's deep
dive on the platform and components,
we'll go over the LM unit, the natural
language unit testing model available as
an endpoint that we will use for our
evaluation. Uh so yeah, back to Raj for
the uh next portion of the workshop.
All right. Yep.
All right. I just need this one.
All right. If anybody knows me, I'd love
to kind of talk and get into the
technical pieces and what's going on a
little bit deeper. So, this is useful
for learning about contextual, but if
you're even building your own rag
pipelines as well, all these components
come into play um to start with. Now, to
start with, how many people have had
issues with hallucinations in their rag
pipelines? Has this been a few? Have
people not have issues? not had issues.
Okay. Yeah, I think everybody Yeah.
finds this.
Now, when we start thinking about
hallucinations, there's a couple of ways
we can think about how to prevent them.
The first is making sure we retrieve
clean information. If we don't do a
great job at extraction, if we don't do
a good job at retrieval, well, then
we're not going to give good information
to that generator model. it makes it the
generator model will then put its own
will try to answer it itself leading to
hallucinations. So that's one big piece.
The next is that language model itself
and we'll talk about that is how we can
ground that language model so it refers
back to the context that it was given
rather than substituting its own
judgment.
And then I want to talk about having
some checks in place because even if you
do that you still want your end users to
be able to trust the system. So I'll
talk about groundness checks as well as
you've already seen it inside the
platform the bounding boxes for
attribution as well.
So to start with when you first build
your first rag project right you need to
extract from some PDFs maybe you've used
like an open source PDF extraction tool.
Have folks used like open source
extraction tools like that PDF plumber
things like that not that many. Have
people been happy with them in terms of
how they've worked for tables and
charts?
Yeah, it's the document on the left is
the easy one, right? That's what you
show in the demos. But you're folks are
going to show up with complex tables,
multimodal, and that's when it gets much
trickier because when you get to these
types of documents,
if you have a parsing error in that
table and things get shifted over,
right, that's going to cause problems
that you can't fix later on. If your
vision language model hallucinates and
add some other information in there when
it's reading that multimodal chart,
right? You're stuck with that, right?
Like that's going to lead to downstream
problems. So making sure you have very
good extraction is like top of the list
when you get to complex documents.
And so this is this is how I like to
think about kind of what we're doing at
contextual right now. It's an evolving
system. We update like every couple
weeks. The engineers probably don't
exactly like how I've diagrammed it like
this, but at least for me, the mental
model works where say you have a PDF
document. The first thing we're going to
do is add some metadata around it,
right? like when was it created? What's
the file name?
Once we have that, then you want to do a
layout analysis. Is this a document
that's image only that we need to do an
OCR for?
Does it have images? Maybe technical
descriptions, multimodal charts, graphs
that we need to add image captioning
where we're going to get a text
description of those features.
If you have tables, we have a special
table extraction mode that focuses on
getting high quality results out of
tables.
Now, beyond that, the structure of the
document also carries meaningful
information, right? What are the section
headers? What are the different
subsections in there? Using that
information can make your make your
extraction go a lot better.
Now once we have that we create a nice
markdown kind of JSON version of that.
I'll show you that in the platform here.
But then for rag use cases we're going
to take those documents and we're going
to chunk them down into smaller pieces
to work with. Right? Because LMS as much
as the long context is growing you can't
take some of these large documents and
chunk them in. And especially there's
the overhaul compute cost of trying to
use those long context fully. So we
create chunks. We use some of that
metadata that we've created inject that
in like knowing the hierarchal structure
of that along the way we set bounding
boxes. This is one reason when we do
image captioning for example we don't
want to take the entire whole page and
do that we like to know where the images
are so we can do bounding box so the
user knows when we say sales went up by
you know 10 $10 they know where on the
page exactly it was.
So within the platform and I know you
can't get to it right now. We have
what's the components you can see on the
left side. Let me see if I can kind of
right there.
All the individual parts of our platform
you can work with individually and we
have a playground for that. So this is
the parse piece here where you can just
take a PDF document decide how you want
the extraction. I just want text or hey
I want the full works where I want image
captioning as well or I have long tables
I want the table extraction mode and you
can do that right inside the UI see what
the results look like now of course
right we're developers we also have an
API Python SDKs JavaScript SDKs as well
so you can do this programmatically as
well
but that's the first step getting that
clean information
next and this is again my my diagram the
engineers would not be happy with this
um the query path.
So once you have that query when your
user is asking a question what's the
process that it goes throughh
first we have a translation module for
folks that for when we need to do that
but the first big step here is the query
reformulation and so here depending on
if you're doing multi-turn we need to
take into account the previous
conversations
query expansion maybe the types of users
are doing lots of abbreviations inside
your So we need to take that query, make
it a little richer and fuller before we
pass that in to get good results. Or on
the other hand, maybe your folks are
putting in long complex queries where
what we want to do is take that query,
break it up into smaller subqueries,
answer each of those. So this is where
you have the flexibility. You can turn
these knobs on and off as you want, as
Nina was showing you in the edit to use
those.
Now once you've gone through that
process that long query might that you
have might break into three sub queries.
Each of those reformulated queries then
passes through your semantic search and
lexical search. So hybrid search kind of
classic best practices there. And then
we give you the option of using a what
we call a data store filter because
maybe your query is asking what's the
revenue of Apple computer and your data
store has Apple, Microsoft, Tesla, all
those documents. Well, if you already
know they they're interested in the
Apple company, why not just filter out
all the other documents so you don't
have to worry about that? That's where
that data store filter comes into play.
Now, typically for retriever, our
defaults are something like a hundred
chunks that will come back.
Retrieval's fast. You can do that.
But then to get better accuracy, we like
to use a reranker. And again, this is
best practices around rag. We've trained
our own the instruction following
reranker. And that helps you go from
that 80 and like the default is 15 but
again you can change it for your
application and give you let's say 15
highquality results that you can then
pass all the way through to the end. We
have another filter stage if you want to
for example drop out some of those as
well. So this is all of these pieces are
orchestrated with lots of different
machine learning models like this. So
this is where it's like a pain to build
this for yourself but we've built this
like this. Now, if I had the time, I'd
go into all those pieces in depth, but I
want to highlight a couple of things. I
like our re-ranker, I think, is
interesting where you have the ability
to provide it instructions. So, a common
one might be, for example, if you're
asking questions about Apple and you
want to get the most recent documents.
So, you can give it a prompt and then
when it reanks those, it's going to look
at the contents of the chunks and use
that prompt to help rerank it. So lot of
possibilities kind of with this and
we're kind of excited to have this piece
there.
Now the last step is generation. So
we've retrieved back all of the query.
Next we're taking it to our grounded
large language model. Again the notion
here is we want a large language model
that's been specifically fine-tuned
on to to respect the knowledge that it's
given not give its own knowledge like
that.
Besides that, we have the two pieces
that I've talked about earlier, the
groundness and the attributions. You've
already seen the attributions, and I'll
talk a little bit more kind of about
groundness.
Now, the grounded language model, since
we trained it ourselves, we got to kind
of do some different things with it. So,
one thing we've done is the language
model will tell you the difference
between facts and commentary.
So, when you have some text, it will
look at that answer and see, hey, this
is the important facts in here. The rest
is just other commentary. So this is
where when you're working with this, if
you want I need a super grounded model,
like I just want the facts in my rag
system. I don't want any of the
superolous stuff like you can turn this
setting on to eliminate the commentary
and just focus on the facts for example.
So this is where kind of training our
own gives us flexibility to do this kind
of thing.
The second thing is is the groundness
check we have. So the groundestness
check works directly in our UI. You can
also use this through the API where for
every response that comes back, what we
do is we look sentence by sentence
essentially and see is the claim that's
made it found in the documents that
we're given.
So here if you look you'll see the
bottom sentence is in yellow.
And it's in yellow because the claim
it's making is a totally BS claim that
it just made up. Right? It's not
actually in the source documents. I
literally prompted it to make up
something.
And so here will automatically in the UI
highlight that's yellow. So if you have
users that you're worried about uh like
they they keep falling for these
hallucinations, this is kind of a helper
feature inside there. And the and the
way it works is when we retrieve all the
context and again you have access to all
the chunks, all the things that are
retrieved.
That answer is going to be generated,
but then we're going to decompose that
answer into specific claims. So we have
a model that just does this
decomposition and looks and sees is this
claim grounded back in that context or
not. So we can run this live at time be
able to get those groundness scores show
you that with the response as well.
All right, Nina's got more on evaluation
like that.
So for our last step of setting up our
rag agent, we will get to the evaluation
step. So, we're going to use our
LMUnunit model for natural language unit
tests, which may be a little bit
different from how you've been doing
evaluation of your RAG system before.
So, we have a fine-tuned model as a
judge, and that has state-of-the-art
performance on Flask and Big Gen Bench.
And the way that it works, as we'll get
into in the notebook shortly, is that
you'll put in um the prompt and get the
model response as your rag system would
generate. And then we're going to create
unit tests for the prompt that will ask
specific questions that you want tested
about those responses. Then we're going
to use the LMU unit model to evaluate
these unit tests and then we can look at
those scores. So we'll be fully in the
notebook now and I have just given up on
the Wi-Fi now. I'm just going to go
through what I ran earlier so we can
just look at the results uh if you had
internet and could run this all on your
own. So
um in this section we have uh
we have commented out the code that we
used to generate the data set. So that
has our set of questions about the data
set uh six questions and then this is
the section that
will generate those results from those
queries. So to save some trees, we just
ran this ahead of time and saved it in
our GitHub. So you could load it
directly. Um
and uh that's uh at this file here. We
have this eval input CSV. Um and then
that just has prompts and responses for
six queries from that same agent that we
set up earlier. And the unit tests we're
going to ask. Uh I thought these would
be interesting ones for this uh for this
document set and the queries. Does the
response accurately extract
specific numerical data from the
documents? Um does the agent properly
distinguish between correlation and
causation that could be useful if you
have some sort of statistical analysis
in your documents? Are multi-document
comparisons performed correctly with
accurate calculations?
Are potential limitations or
uncertainties in the data clearly
acknowledged?
Are quantitative claims properly
supported with specific evidence from
the source documents? And does the
response avoid unnecessary information?
We know that uh LLMs like to blab on and
on in their response. So, this is a good
unit test. I think overall uh some of
the other ones you can set based on your
own documents if you want to try this
out later. And so we just set up our
unit tests here. Um,
and then
the LMU unit model will score on a one
to five scale and it's been fine-tuned
for this specific task. And so then the
next block of code that you would run
would be this uh response generation. So
we put in our query. What was Nvidia's
data center revenue in Q4 fiscal year
25?
And then you get your response and that
does have the uh the correct amount, the
citation, but then it has a lot of other
information. And so the unit test we
used was does the response avoid
unnecessary information. And the score
was 2.2 out of five. So, for example, if
we wanted to, if this was an important
criteria for us, then we could later
update the system prompt or change some
of those other settings to specifically
target this um the results from this
unit test. Of course, we don't want to
operate from an N of one. So, um we are
now testing this batch of six, which of
course again is a small batch. This was
meant to run in, uh real time if we had
internet. Um, and this would just run
through all of those six queries and all
of those six unit tests to get the
results. Then this is the line here. Um,
run unit tests with progress. This uh
will give you the results from those
unit tests. And so here we can look at
those results. We can see the prompt
response and um and then we can see the
scores here for each of our six unit
tests and those are going to be from one
to five. Um and then we can also then
map those long sentences to just a
one-word category. So just accuracy,
causation, synthesis, limitations,
evidence, and relevance. You can set
these as you'd like. And we're going to
create polar plots that show us uh for
example for our second question, what is
the coefficient between Neptune's
distance from the sun and US burglary
rates? We can see in the polar plot that
um the causation was very well addressed
by our model. The accuracy and
limitations also scored high on the unit
test, but the synthesis was not as
highly scored. Um and these other
factors were not as highly scored. So we
can look at all six and uh we can kind
of see some of these queries scored
really well across all our unit tests.
Others may point to areas to improve. We
linked earlier to the full LMU unit
notebook where you can look at these
categories and uh cluster them. So for a
larger scale evaluation data set, you
could actually like look for um for
meaningful inite insights from this unit
test. Um, and so, uh, your first
homework, if you've made it this far is
to improve the agent based on the unit
test results. And so, one way that you
could do that in the API would be uh,
here to update the system prompt. So, I
have our original one and you could, you
know, change something here like, hey,
keep the responses really brief, only
answer um, uh, the direct question. And
then you can run this line of code here
to update the agent. And um and yeah,
that's our that's our endto-end
pipeline. And now for a bonus, Raj is
going to show you how you can connect
your agent to claw desktop via MCP. And
for that, we have links to our GitHub
here and the YouTube how-to if you want
to try this out yourself. Um
Okay. Yeah. Yeah.
I'm dealing with the challenges of the
Wi-Fi and working around that. So, let's
talk about this. See if we can get this
running.
So, for lucky for all of you, I spend
way too much time making videos. So, I
have a copy of the video integration
that I want to show. So, we built a rag
agent. You can ask questions, right? You
want to be able to use it. One of the
most common ways of being able to use
it, right, that was introduced what like
six months ago here um at AI engineer
was MCP server. So one of the things I
like to do is kind of show people how I
can connect the rag agents that we built
at contextual and you can use them
inside of other MCP clients. And so
here's an example of using it inside of
claw desktop where now when it has this
particular topic, it's going out to the
contextual rag agent to be able to get
the answer to do that. So you can do
this working inside of clients like
claude. You can also be able to do this
for example if you're working with code
you want to be able to do this in
something like cursor that works as
well.
So to do this, if you're like, hey, I
want to do this. I want to be able to
use this rag agent everywhere else to do
that, we have a repo that's out there.
So the contextual MCP server, it's the
the link is in the notebook as well. So
you can grab that. It's an it's a very
basic MCP server. You could probably
build your own. Let us know. Um like
that. But the workflow is you clone that
repo and then inside that repo there's a
server. py file and we're just using our
contextual
um our contextual APIs and just pointing
to that. So the important thing of
course is that doc string that you kind
of describe what your rag agent is about
because that's what your client whether
it's clawed or cursor is going to be
able to use that. So to make this a
little bit more,
here's a copy for example inside of mine
where
you can see in my local environment I
have that MCP server locally hosted.
This is what my server.py file looks
like where you can see I've got two
different ones set up. One for technical
queries, one for financial queries
depending on who I demo to. and it can
have the client then pull in to that
piece there.
So that's the this the server that's
sitting in the middle. The next piece is
configuring it with your client. And
every client's a little bit different
like that, but you just want to be able
to have that client point to where that
server file is. So if we look at for
example in the case of cloud desktop
which is not running now but luckily we
can still do this
in claude desktop has a developer piece
where you can edit the config for where
it should look for MCP servers and if I
click here edit config I can go see the
file that it's there we can open that up
we're not going to open it up in cursor
but you get a sense that's the config
file that's going to point towards where
my server ever location is. So again, if
you're not sure about this, I have all
the directions on the GitHub. There's an
accompanying video as well, but it just
allows you to use that rag agent now in
lots of other ways as well. For example,
if you're building your own deep
research tool, you want to be able to do
that, you can do that.
All right, we're going to open it up for
questions here in a couple of minutes.
And again, if you're having any issues,
raise your hand. We got a couple of
people in the back that can help out.
So one question often is is like what is
this going to cost me? Like you give me
the sales pitch, what is it going to
cost me? Well, if you use our individual
components, the pars, the rerank, the
generate LM unit, we've made that all
consumption based. You pay by the token
for those. So the pricing is up on the
website. It's pretty straightforward
like that. Um when you've signed up
today, you started off with a $25
credit. So you should be able to go
start playing around with it as well.
So those are the individual components.
We're also making our rag platform
consumptionbased pricing as well. So the
pricing will be based on the number of
documents you ingest and how many
queries you do. So based on that you'll
be able to kind of calculate out know
what your workload is like that. Now
some we I work with some enterprise
customers for some sensitive places
they're like hey we really need a
guarantee on latency or amount of
queries per second like that. This is
where we can work with that team do a
provision throughput so that way you
have dedicated kind of hardware for your
particular use case like that. But I
think one of the great things that's
going to really open it up to developers
is the consumption base because just
like you're doing today, you're going to
be able to sign up pass documents
through that and just pay for what you
use like that.
All right. So some final takeaways I'm
hoping that you got out of this that how
you can treat rag just as any other
managed service. You don't have to go
through build out all those pipelines
yourself like that. You've got the code.
You can get started now building this
pipeline individually or if you just
need parts of it, just the components,
try them out as well. You your reranker
you're not happy with, give it a shot.
So go try out the app to do that. All of
this stuff is documented over in docs.
We have kind of full API docs over
there. We also have a bunch of example
notebooks showing for example
integrations with things like Ragus as
well if you want to use that for
evaluation. So, those example notebooks
will walk you through, hey, how do I
improve an agent? How would I use all of
these settings? If you need other
example notebooks, let us know. Nina and
I will work on that as well. So,
finally, fill out our survey, kind of
share your feedback as well. We've got
some nice kind of merch we can hand out
to people who have good questions as
well. I think we got a little bit of
time for that. How does that sound?
I've thrown this rag platform at you.
Are you all ready to sign up? Oh, okay.
Yeah. Go. Go ahead. When you found
people using this platform,
there's an interesting feedback.
There's a Q&A mic or I'll try to repeat
back the question to the wider audience.
So if you want my interpretation of the
question or
I can't massage it then is that on? Yes.
Yeah. Um so there's a really interesting
feedback you're defining here around you
can define evals via prompt. You can see
how they're doing. You can let people
change the system prompt. Do you find
that your users of like the platform or
the enterprise customers like who is it
that's doing that? Is it like technical
people or is it the people that's using
it dayto-day?
So one of the things by putting it in
the UI what you have is you have some of
the business users will try to mess
around and play with it and some pieces
like a system prompt like non-technical
people have a sense of using chatpt and
doing that but when you get to what's
your my top K for my retrieval or using
query reformulation those business users
are just going to mess up and their
agents are going to kind of not stop
work well like that. So, a lot of the
settings there as you get to the
advanced hill climbing because a lot of
that stuff comes into like I've built a
good rag agent, it's hitting 80%, but
the business wants us to get to 90%.
Now, I have to build the evaluation.
Now, I have to see where are my errors.
Are they on the retrieval side? Are they
on the generator side? And this is where
having that developer perspective of
understanding and being able to do that
error analysis is important to figure
out which of those settings to do it
because we give you a lot of settings
but you still have to have some sense of
like which settings are appropriate to
change for what outcomes like that.
Um company I work for is relatively new
to AI. We're loving what we're
discovering, but uh it's also pretty
overwhelming. Uh the information you
presented uh hints at some of the
answers to to our major questions, which
are we have thousands of PDF documents,
we have thousands of of you know, Excel
documents, we have an MRP system with an
SQL back end. Do we need to be writing
custom queries for this environment to
consume? Um I guess does your
environment have a checklist of the
approach for different data types and
how to package this information for your
environment? Yeah, I I could repeat back
the question like that. So so the
question is is and I'll paraphrase you
getting into it. We have lots of
documents. We have Excel documents, PDF
documents, structured data. Like how am
I going to make sense of that and figure
out what the best way to kind of use
your platform is? Is that fair? Yeah.
Yes. And so this is where as a startup
we have a couple of different levels. We
have we have the developer go figure it
out yourself. We've given you the
buttons, the API commands to do that.
But this is where we've grown and we
have a dedicated team that we call
customer machine learning engineers that
all they do is work with customers and
they do that process of hey let's walk
you through building your evaluation
data sets. Let's help you kind of hill
climb and improve that. So depending on
what you need, we have a team that's
just focused on helping customers
through that process as well. And in the
meantime, N and I are trying to document
it and make it more available for the
rest of the users, but there is that gap
of like there's a lot of knowledge to
effectively use these systems to be able
to do that. Is that fair? And it's a
consulting fee or a startup package.
Yeah. Talk to us. We we can we got we'll
find a way to take your money.
little uh go ahead.
Hey Rajie. Um
um we've built a few agents and I'm very
interested in exploring the rag only
part of like what you described. Is
there a way to integrate these into our
agents that we're building in Typescript
JavaScript?
Absolutely. So each of the Okay. Yes. I
don't have to repeat. So each of the
pieces here we have kind of APIs. We
have a we have a JavaScript SDK like
that. So if you just want to use the
components of this, this is where when
the company first started about a year
ago, if you'd asked to kind of do a
demo, we would have sold you like you
have to buy the entire platform, you
have to get the end to end. But we've
realized like if we want to appeal to
developers that lots of times you've
built stuff out that you just want some
components of it. So yes, we we've kind
of modularized that out. So if you just
want to use parts of it, you can and
integrate with others like that. So, and
in fact, you know, most of our customers
don't use like the UI that we've showed,
most of them have other UIs that they're
integrating their applications with like
that. So,
in response, in addition to the costing
or pricing, um, how far can the $25 go?
Like, because we weren't able to test it
right now, like how many documents can
we, you know, experiment on it, you
know? So, the question is like how far
will your $25 go?
I I I don't know exactly. I get
unlimited use of it. Um but try it out.
If if you run into issues, just let us
know. We can we can talk to sales. We
can figure out something like that if
depending on what you're doing like
that. So don't let the $25 be an issue.
We want the we want you to use it. We
want to hear your feedback. If you need
help, let we can talk to you and figure
out something to do like that. So yes,
do people like the idea of a manage rag
service? Does this feel like something?
Okay. Okay. Okay. Yes. Well, to that
point because I'm wondering how managed
is it? So, at my company, we build rag
applications for government and other
clients who have really strict data
sovereignty, data residency questions uh
or requirements. So, are you in either
of the big clouds where I can decide to
be in like a gov cloud or some other
sovereign data service? like how much
control do I have over where stuff
lives? Yeah. So again, we're early stage
startup. We're starting out right now.
We have our own cloud which doesn't help
you like that. We have partnered with
Snowflake. So we are on Snowflake if
that can work for you. We can also
install in VPC, but right now we're
limiting it to VPC. We're not doing kind
of custom on premises deployment just
because that takes a lot of upfront work
to be able to do like that. Does that
help?
Yeah. Can you do VPC and say like AWS
GovCloud or Azure's government solution?
We have not yet done like AWS in kind of
GovCloud like that like if you have a
strong demand for that let us know. We
can we can work and try to figure out
something like that but we haven't taken
on that yet. Okay. I'll come find you.
Thanks. Yes. Thanks.
Hello. Hi.
Yeah. Go ahead. Hi. I was curious you
know like how does the performance of
your rack platform vary as a number of
documents vary for example like do you
have like recommendations of best
practices when you're working with
millions of documents as compared to
hundreds of documents what kind of you
know configurations and knobs work
better would be curious to learn yeah so
I'm going to give the handwavy answer of
we have customers like Qualcomm for
example that have tens of thousands of
docu documents their documents have
hundreds of pages in them and we handle
that fine all I know is that I have
engineers like Matthew in the back that
works the platform that makes sure it
kind of scales up like that. So I would
say go grab him if you have questions
about scalability. Right now we've been
able to kind of scale with our customers
um along those lines like that. So
let me take this and I'll come back over
here. Hey this is specifically about the
LMUN um tool. Um how deterministic and
repeatable are the are the is the
scoring from that
I'm looking to see if they have I I mean
it's still a large language model so I
think there might be a little bit but I
think it it's fairly good
it's pretty
there's a lot more details there too but
like there was a lot of analysis done
about the correlation with other metrics
and you know how you know running sorry
running the LMU unit tests
repeatedly making like um we use kind of
a random seed to make sure it's
repeatable. So like all of our testing
has suggested that uh it is repeatable.
Of course like you're if you're like
altering the prompt or altering kind of
the natural language unit test that can
have you know unforeseen impacts on the
results but I think keeping the prompt
consistent it should be pretty
consistent with different types of
queries. Awesome. Thank you. Yeah, check
out the paper as as Matthew said that it
goes into a lot of those pieces like
that. So, thanks
question here. Yeah. So, is this already
integrated with uh Microsoft Copilot and
Azure? And the second question is uh are
there any APIs that you guys exposing
it? Meaning if we are developing our own
custom code but we want to you know use
your rack and what's approach. So we
have the API. So if you're developing
your own custom solutions, you can
easily integrate kind of what we have to
do that in terms of installing inside of
kind of um Azure like that. That's one
of those custom VPCs that we can support
like that. In terms of integrations with
C-pilot, I don't know if we've really
done anything. Usually like people are
like I'm sick of Copilot and that's why
they come to our rag solution like that.
So again we have the APIs though so I
don't know what the integrations would
require for something like copilot like
that.
Thank you.
Hi first of all great presentation
because I have used your product and the
other thing is like regarding rag I have
a question like uh you as a company what
are the challenges that you are facing
in the rag and where do you see rag
would go in future?
So what are the challenges we're facing
in rag apart from hallucination,
internet search or things like that?
Apart from that, what are the different
challenges that you're facing?
Matthew, I might have you chime in on
this too. I think
one of the big challenges right now is
around the extraction where we've spent
a lot of time and energy and there's
still I think room for improvement when
we're talking about working with complex
tables along charts. I think there's one
there. I think scalability is always a
piece like that because everybody wants
to ingest more documents in a in a
faster amount of speed like that.
I think if you talk about doing
generated um working with structured
data, I think that's a challenge for
everybody in the industry when you're
trying to do those queries of like text
to SQL type queries like that. So th
those are some of the top ones on my
list like that. Do you have Yeah, I
agree. I think document understanding
like making sure that you are correctly
understanding long complex documents
with hierarchy and interreations between
sections and really large tables and
gnarly figures like I think that has
been a consistent thing that we've been
working on and seeing improvements on
but there's definitely still room to
grow there. Um I think another kind of
broader change in the rag space that our
research team is very focused on and it
hasn't directly translated into our
product yet but it's kind of coming soon
is um moving away from the more like
static rag pipelines that Raj like
beautifully described in his
presentation toward kind of a fully
dynamic flow with you model routers uh
at certain kind of inflection points
deciding which tools to use how many
times to retrieve you know how to alter
the retrieval config in in order to
correctly answer the query. So I I think
those sorts of like dynamic workflows
will greatly increase what you can
answer with any rag platform. Um almost
like deep research for rag uh is one way
to think about it and I think that's
something that our research team is
working very hard on and will be like
coming into our platform in the nearish
future. Great. Thanks.
Come back in six months.
uh do you have plans for a public facing
like a web search feature particularly
one that could be configured on a
company's domain?
So are what you are you looking for kind
of a general I need to be able to search
the internet because like there's
tavilla firecrawl places like that or
it's more that companies that have
public facing websites where it makes
sense to instead of running rag on your
like CMS database you're actually just
you want to run it on that live and so
John I might pull you in here because I
think one of the things John's worked
with quite a bit because a lot of what
that requires is the integrations to be
able to pull pull from that from those
sources as well. And so I know John,
you've done some of those things for
customers with fire crawl pieces. Yeah.
Sorry, what was the question for me
again? About ingesting customer websites
and being able to use that in rag. Oh
yeah. So, um there's a lot of like uh
ways that you can scrape for websites or
like directly like um kind of set up
like an ETL pipeline with like pulling
the records from the APIs or just
pulling the unstructured data from like
a data cloud um or blob storage and then
kind of just setting up like an
ingestion queue which is what we do on
our side for larger customers. Um or
basically any customer that needs like a
kickstart for lots of data coming in. Um
some customers are like super happy to
write their own scripts or like their
own kind of functions or daily quan jobs
to update uh documents but we're also
working on like a managed solution on
our side so that you can just give us
your credentials and then on our front
end and then we'll just start pulling
and syncing all the data on our back end
but that's like something coming on the
road map in like two to three months
and so please if there's pieces like
that you see that you want us let us
know because we like to kind of push the
product team to kind of make that stuff
happen. So
all right. Yeah. Hi. Hi. How do you deal
with uh frequently updated content and
uh uh document level permissions if not
everybody can see specific documents?
Yes. So those are both tricky things.
One of the things we'll do for
frequently um frequently updated
documents is we have a continuous
ingestion pipeline. John, if you can
talk to in the back can talk to you more
about that piece as well. So that's one
piece for the frequently updated for the
other piece is the harder one
entitlements. How do you deal with all
the permissions, right? Like you're
indexing HR rag stuff next to customer
support stuff. How do you make sure that
the person doesn't look up the salaries
of anybody else like that? So this is
where within our platform, one of the
things we're adding is an entitlements
layer like that. Because as we've talked
to lots of customers, they're like,
"This is nice." When you do it over our
customer support, but inside of a real
enterprise, we have governance, we have
permissions, we have to be able to
respect that when we do these types of
searches. And so we're adding an
entitlements layer on top of ours to be
able to handle that. So yeah, that's an
important piece. All right. Hi. U So my
question is regarding in last six
months, what are some of the major
breakthroughs in rag area if you can?
What are the major breakthroughs in the
last six months in the RAG area? Um,
so I think the re-rankers continue to
get better. I think that's that's an
easy place um where we've seen that. I
mean, I think part of it is just every
piece of that has steadily been getting
better. I think one of the biggest
changes you've seen in the last 6 months
year is the rise of the vision language
models and how strong they are at being
able to handle kind of images like that.
That's that's off the top of my head. I
see Matthew's busy talking to somebody
else, otherwise I'd have him weigh in as
well. Does that help? Yes.
Um, does the contextual parser module
can replace like doc or GCP invoice
parsers and things like this? And if if
it does, does it have the ability to
parse QR codes and barcodes and instruct
their metadata to kind of read that data
as well? Yes. So I think one of the
things is there's a lot of different
types of documents out there in terms of
document types and there's a lot of
different solutions. So I don't we're
not going to be able to handle every
type of thing perfectly like that. I
think there's going to be lots of pieces
but this is where we've made those APIs
so you can try that out um on those
piece like we haven't specifically
focused on for example that type of
document. We do have the image
captioning so maybe it would pick them
up maybe it wouldn't like that. But the
idea here is to go in that same space
where there's a lot of these other
companies doing this parsing thing and
making sure that we have a module that
you can just stick in and replace and
kind of use with ours like that. So
yes, how do you deal with domain
specific language?
That's a good question. How do you deal
with domain specific language? And and
this can get a little tricky and we've
seen it for example when we're working
with technical companies that have very
specific words that they use inside
there where on one hand you can do
things like changing system prompts a
little bit um for the retriever part.
But sometimes what we've done with some
of those customers is fine-tune that
grounded language model that's closer to
their vocabulary and how they speak. And
that's been one technique we've used now
and this is where at one point in the
platform we had that available to end
developers but fine-tuning models can
get a little complex for using for rag.
So we've kind of put that away now and
that's more for kind of our
serviceoriented customers that work with
our customer machine learning engineers.
But that's one thing we've done to if
that knowledge is out there and you need
to get that into your grounded language
model is to do a kind of a fine-tuning
process step.
Go ahead. Oh, I don't know where the mic
is.
We're making them run, getting their
steps in today.
Hey, um, so how about HIPPAs
like PHI data like this kind of stuff
like how you deal with that? Should we
hash it before go to the platform or the
LLM can can understand and and deal with
that? So there's two aspects to that.
One is we just got HIPPA certified that
people are going to think I'm paying the
audience members out there. Um like
that. The second is is well what do you
do in extraction? Like maybe I have PHI
data. I want you to automatically mask
or filter that. So this is one thing
that we've been talking with a product
team about whether to include that
capability for during that parsing piece
um to automatically kind of flag and
identify that that behavior. Right now
we don't kind of have that in the
product. But again like if that's
something you need or want let us know.
It's not that hard to kind of build on,
but you can also do that as a supplement
to the parsing and have a second job
that runs and looks for that PII
information. Does that help? Good. Uh, I
know garbage in, garbage out, but if we
have a document with say two different
numbers on a particular like statistic
or fact, how does your rag deal with
that or how would it answer a question?
Yeah.
So what what happens in that case is
often the retrieval is going to bring
both of those pieces of information over
to the grounded language model and it's
going to be up to the language model to
use its reasoning ability to try to
reason out the two differences. So
sometimes if one is for example if it's
obvious that one is not like let's let's
let's say it's the size of a mosquito
and one of the answers is 100 feet and
the other is right like 3 millimeters
the the language model is going to know
like one of these is junk and to ignore
it. But if they're both close and
reasonable yes that that can get you in
trouble um with with those pieces like
that. So I assume this is a pain that
you're having now.
like not updated.
And so we're just trying to we're just
trying to see how we can organize that.
Um because a lot of my job right now is
just telling people information that
should be in a document but it's not
updated. So So one thing that can help
with that is taking advantage of
metadata and using as much rich
information about those documents. So
when at retrieval time it can help it
kind of figure out like hey these are
the two differences and this is why I
should prioritize this answer over
another answer like maybe this is the
most recent or this was written by the
authoritative person like that like
that's like one one thing that we kind
of recommend for those use cases like
that. Thank you. All right.
Okay. Well thank you all for staying.
I've loved the kind of the questions
like this. Please use the application.
Give us feedback on how you're finding
that as well. good, bad, negative. H
happy to take that all like that. So,
thank you again for kind of spending
your morning with us like that. Anything
else we have, Nina, or we good? Oh,
you've got the mic off.
I think I still have my mic. Uh, yeah,
I've been going around distributing swag
to folks that have asked questions.
Sorry if I missed some of you that were
farther away. I have one more pair of
socks. Anyone wants them? The guy in the
back wants the socks.
All right. Yeah.
All right. Thank you all. We'll be
hanging around for a little while if you
have that. So,
[Music]